from time Lords to zombie Slayers many
actors are just never satisfied with
their roles yet some come to regret
their decisions later on in life Doctor
Who has returned to television in 2005
was rightfully met with much fanfare it
was now a cinematic action spectacular
headlined by Scottish actor Christopher
Eccleston as the ninth iteration of the
famous doctor but part of that
excitement was dampened when axelson
decided to leave the show after just 13
episodes the reason for the quick split
creative differences with producers
speaking to the Daily Record Eccleston
said I'd had enough I wanted to do it my
way they wanted something else we were
never going to compromise so it was best
to be straight about it and just go but
maybe that wasn't the best move a while
later Eccleston told the Australian
radio show drive that he wishes he could
have stayed on a bit longer he expressed
how he enjoyed the character and
believes a second season would have been
better for his version of the doctor
Will Wheaton scored two of the biggest
and most impactful teen roles of the
1980s back to back Gordy in Stand By Me
and the boy Genius Wesley Crusher in
Star Trek the Next Generation after four
seasons on the show Wheaton walked away
from his job as a regular cast member in
1990. right around the time that he
turned 18. he did however return for the
occasional guest spot until the show
ended in 1994. it wasn't until 2012
during a Next Generation cast reunion on
stage at the Calgary comic and
Entertainment Expo that Wheaton let the
world know just how much he regretted
his decision to step off of the
Enterprise he said I was 18 years old
and initially I thought it was a really
smart business career move in some ways
it was and in more ways it wasn't what I
wasn't prepared for was how much I was
going to miss the people on this stage
he explained how he was so devoted to
forging his own way in the world that he
didn't see his co-stars for a while he
added how he felt embarrassed for his
behavior and didn't even invite them to
his wedding after he crossed paths with
his co-stars at Fan conventions he
apologized and rekindled those
friendships I'm not done
by its 10th and final season Beverly
Hills 90210 was no longer set in and
around West Beverly Hills High School in
focused on the adultish Romantic social
and professional lives of a bunch of
SoCal friends many original cast members
had long ago moved on including Luke
Perry and Shannen Doherty a few episodes
into the ninth season the show star
Jason Priestley decided it was time to
try something new as well his character
Brendan Walsh took a job at the
Washington DC Bureau of a New York
newspaper speaking to CNN years later
Priestly explained how he felt he had
done everything there was to do with his
character and that there weren't more
roads to travel down that said he did
regret his decision to depart since it
didn't allow closure for Brandon and
Kelly's romantic Arc he added
understanding what I do now about story
and character I believe that Aaron
Spelling would have had Brandon and
Kelly end up together at the end of the
show and I think I probably should have
stuck around to its fruition
Gray's Anatomy made Katherine Heigl
famous but it's also where she earned a
reputation for being reportedly
difficult to work with in 2008 she
withdrew her name from consideration at
that Year's Emmy Awards releasing a
statement explaining that she didn't
believe the material was good enough for
her to receive a nomination eight years
later she explained on the Howard Stern
Show that it wasn't a slight against the
writers or Creator Shonda Rhimes she
simply meant she didn't like her
performance on Gray's Anatomy Heigl also
explained that she had personally
apologized to Rhymes in 2010 she left
the show to spend more time with her
family and pursue a movie career just
two years later Heigl wondered if her
exit had been premature when asked by
Barbara Walters on a 2012 episode of The
View if she regretted leaving Gray's
Anatomy Heigl admitted she did she added
I always felt that if they wanted me to
come back and sort of wrap up that
storyline I want them to know that I'm
down with it if they want me to good
Lord what did I say
Matt Smith portrayed the 11th iteration
of the titular Time Lord on Doctor Who
being 26 at the time he was the youngest
actor to ever play the part and he
brought an infectious youthful energy to
the role it also turned the previously
little-known British TV actor into an
international Superstar who went on to
an emmy-nominated turn on the crown for
most of his who tenure he co-starred
opposite Karen Gillen who portrayed the
doctor's time and space travel companion
Amy Pond Gillen left the show before
Smith did and producers replaced her
with Jenna Coleman as a new companion
the doctor regenerated into a new form
that looked just like actor Peter
Capaldi after Smith shared the screen
with Coleman in just 12 episodes a
number Smith later said wasn't enough at
the 2016 New York Comic-Con he said
that's one of my great regrets that I
didn't get a full season with Jenna but
if you believe Doctor Who writer Stephen
Moffitt it's not just his short run with
Coleman that Smith regrets speaking to
the mirror Moffat said Smith wishes he
never left at all
intense actor David Caruso is certainly
best known for his meme inspiring
performance as crime inspector Horatio
Kane on CSI Miami that pushed the
previous thing that had made Caruso
famous to the back of the collective
Consciousness in 1993 he vaulted from
obscure character actor to TV Superstar
with a role in the Smash Hit police
drama NYPD Blue Caruso received an Emmy
nomination and a Golden Globe win for
his role as detective John Kelly but he
still left a hugely popular show after
just one season he thought he could make
it in movies though that didn't quite
happen the 1995 crime Thrillers kiss of
death and Jade both flopped at the box
office after that Caruso didn't book a
gig for two years he then starred in a
couple of forgettable movies and the
quickly canceled CBS drama Michael Hayes
the actor finally returned to prominence
with CSI Miami that long crawled back
taught Caruso a thing or two speaking to
the Sioux City Journal about his NYPD
Blue departure he said I've been pretty
upfront about admitting I messed up on a
great opportunity I did understand what
the priority of the day is about that's
what happens when Worlds Collide
fans love McLean Stevenson in his
supporting role on Mash as the laid-back
Colonel Henry Blake but in 1975 after
three seasons on the show Stevenson got
a niche to do something bigger according
to mash writer Ken Levine Stevenson
received many offers during that time to
start in his own show and so he left it
wasn't widely done in the 1970s but the
writer simply killed off his character
Stevenson then had to endure the death
of his television career after Mash he
starred in one high-profile quickly
canceled flop after another such as the
McLean Stevenson show and the TV version
of Dirty Dancing in 1990 after that
streak's merciful end Stevenson
reflected on his TV career for the
Baltimore Sun he said I made the mistake
of believing that people were enamored
of McLean Stevenson when the person they
were enamored of was Henry Blake
Stevenson admitted that he hadn't worked
with a group of people as good as the
mash crew since he left the show
ER slowly shed all six of its original
cast members Anthony Edwards left after
season eight while George Clooney
disappeared after season 5 only to make
a special appearance in season six and
then there's Sherry Stringfield she left
ER early in its run and then came back
as a full-fledged cast member a few
years down the line from 1994 to 1996
Stringfield for trade Emergency
Physician Susan Lewis on the hit NBC
medical drama she worked sporadically
over the next few years in 2001 she she
had a baby which made her long for and
appreciate the schedule that comes with
shooting a weekly television show
speaking to the Chicago Tribune
Stringfield revealed how she started to
look for something more consistent
rather than find a new show she thought
it would be easier to go back to ER so
she spoke to executive producer John
Wells about the possibility of coming
back Stringfield said I met with John
Wells and I was like I'd love to come
back and he said okay we'd love to have
you back that was it then I moved read
the first script and showed up for work
it was really that easy
as Saturday Night Live revolutionized TV
with its first season many of the
original cast of not ready for Prime
Time Players became overnight Stars
particularly Chevy Chase after all he
was the one who played President Gerald
Ford and hosted Weekend Update where he
coined the catchphrase I'm Chevy Chase
and you're not like many SNL Stars after
him Chase left the show to pursue a film
career which proved successful with
movies like Caddyshack in the vacation
series unlike others though Chase left
SNL ridiculously fast exiting after
about a year during the SNL 40th
anniversary festivities in 2015 Chase
told Carson Daly I left after the first
year because I thought this isn't going
anywhere he admitted he enjoyed his time
on the show and mostly missed being a
part of the cast
laughs
Ellen Cleghorn was an extremely talented
part of the extremely overloaded
Saturday Night Live cast of the early
1990s she had to compete for precious
air time each week with the likes of
Chris Farley Phil Hartman Dana Carvey
David Spade and Adam Sandler among
others even so she told VH1 that others
advocated for her particularly Sandler
and writer performer Al Franken who
taught her how to write sketches during
her time on the show she developed two
recurring characters queen shniqua and
zaraida the NBC page she also
impersonated other newsmakers of the
time in 1995 right around the same time
SNL boss Lauren Michaels fired several
cast members in favor of New Blood
Cleghorn quit the show the reason the WB
picked up her sitcom Cleghorn that show
was ultimately canceled after just one
low rated season Cleghorn still has
mixed feelings about her SNL departure
though speaking to VH1 she said I wish I
would have stayed at Saturday Night Live
but I'm so glad that I had the
opportunity to do Cleghorn it was
important at the time for me but I did
miss being on SNL
Andrew Lincoln was an original cast
member of The Walking Dead when the AMC
zombie drama began the first episode
found his character Small Town police
sheriff Rick Grimes Awakening from a
coma to discover a post-zombie
apocalyptic Wasteland Lincoln stayed
with the show before deciding to move on
during season 9. in a 2018 episode Rick
disappears after a bridge explosion
presumed dead to the rest of the show's
main characters but he was actually
hauled away in a helicopter belonging to
the Civic Republic military at the time
producers of The Walking Dead explained
the subsequent absence of Lincoln with
the promise of Standalone movies
concerning the Further Adventures of
Rick Grimes those never came to fruition
canceled in favor of a limited series
about the post-apocalyptic Adventures of
Rick and his Once and Future partner
Michonne Lincoln returned to The Walking
Dead proper just once and briefly in the
2022 series finale that was perhaps
telegraphed by co-star Norman Reedus
while promoting the season 9 finale the
actor shared that Lincoln had some
regrets about departing The Walking Dead
when it was hitting its stride
foreign